l'alberta a besoin d' aide tout le
secteur des ressources naturelles
réclame énormément de soutien avec nous
ce soir pour en parler martha hall
findlay directrice du développement
durable chez son corps martha hall
findlay bonsoir bonsoir
jason kenney a dit clairement ça prend
20 milliards pour aider de l'alberta
est-ce que chez suncor vous avez besoin
d aide
honnêtement je suis fier d'être avec une
entreprise assez forte
il y en a qui ont beaucoup plus de
difficultés c'est vrai on a vu aussi
qu'après à 2008
après les difficultés de diminuer suncor
et petro-canada sont rendus ensemble ça
nous donne à 100 pour une situation
vraiment diversifié nous sommes une
entreprise intégrée complètement
nous avons des raffineries par exemple
raffine une grande raffinerie à montréal
les opérations sur le co2 est alors ça
nous rend plus capable de voir la
lumière à la fin ça mais avez vous
besoin des aides pour le moment
honnêtement non honnêtement mais c'est
l'industrie qui en a beaucoup besoin et
on dit ça parce que par exemple il ya
les ce qu'on entend par exemple
gouvernement parle un petit peu on
envisage de financer la saisie
l'assainissement de puisage abandonné ce
n'est pas pour ce en quoi on n'a pas de
puits abandonnés mais si si c'est
possible et on peut garder des emplois
et des emplois
avec des compétences qui sont importants
particulièrement si ou quand on revient
un petit peu ça c'est très bon pour
l'industrie alors ce en cours on appuie
des opportunités comme ça où des
subventions on voit ce que le
gouvernement fédéral vient d'annoncer
avec le subvention de salaire oui on
trouve ça vraiment intéressant parce que
est vraiment parce que ça n'a rien à
faire avec le secteur ça n'a rien à
faire avec les la grandeur l'ampleur de
l'entreprise entreprises seraient c'est
vraiment pour nous on sait que quand
quelques paires un emploi un emploi
perdu c'est un emploi perdu et est donc
ça pourrait être intéressant prévente et
donc ça pourrait être intéressant pour
vous d'avoir la subvention salariale
pour le moment on en a pas besoin que
mais on ne sait pas combien de temps ça
va durer
alors on le veut on le voit vraiment
avec intérêt c'est clair ok à moins de 3
dollars le baril le wcs le western
canada select 2 dollars 76 aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on arrête de produire du
pétrole à ce prix là c'est intéressant
c'est une bonne question on a vu les
discussions a parmi les membres de
l'opep et tout mon bar de la décision de
réduire la production
honnêtement au canada particulièrement
on a déjà commencé à arrêter réduire la
production parce que un le prix et on
perd de l'argent si on produit
oui pris tout ça mais aussi il n'y a
plus place pour le stockage les
réservoirs sont pleins partout dans le
monde les réservoirs commence à être
plein alors on ne peut pas produire s'il
n'y a pas de place pour le m alors on a
vu que
le ministre avait dit madame sage a dit
clairement il ne faut pas demander le
premier ministre qui connais on dit in
faut et il ne faut pas demander à
alberta au canada de réduire notre
production
c'était parce qu'on a déjà réduit notre
production et on continue à le garder
moins de ce qu'on avait mais c'est
vraiment à cause du prix et c'est
vraiment à cause du fait qu'on a trop de
pétrole la ministre savait que la
ministre de l'énergie en alberta est-ce
que suncor a parce que son corps avait
des projets je voyais les prévisions
pour 2020 qui avaient été publiées en
décembre on parlait de 6 milliards de
dollars en immobilisations est ce que
les projets d'investissement de son
corps sont tombés à l'eau pour l'instant
pour l'instant est pas tous les projets
mais plusieurs c'est clair on a eu
besoin de réduire beaucoup nos dépenses
en capital
on est en train de trouver les
réductions des dépenses d'exploitation
nous sommes focalisés sur garder nos
emplois
honnêtement mais c'est dommage parce
qu'il ya plusieurs projets comme par
exemple il faut me permettez
l'anglicisme de cogénération plainte la
seconde génération c'est un projet qui
aurait réduit nos gaz à effet de serre
et les gaz à effet de serre de province
de l'alberta aussi nous nous sommes
vraiment fiers de ce projet mais on
avait besoin au moins de leur porter un
petit peu alors on verra mais mais c'est
vrai on n'a pas eu de choses pas eu d'
option que de réduire les dépenses comme
ça c'est pour ça que quand je parle
d'être une entreprise forte au moins on
peut faire des choses comme ça pour pour
rester à flot est ce que c'est le
conflit la guerre de prix arabie
saoudite la russie qui fait le plus mal
ou c'est la coved 19 en ce moment a
simplement le kobe 19
m absolument c'est c'est la réduction en
demande la réduction de l'utilisation du
pétrole beaucoup beaucoup plus important
que ce qui est arrivé avec l'arabie
saoudite et la russie
nice l'a pas aidé et c'est pour ça que
la décision il ya deux trois jours avec
au peuple ça va aider mais honnêtement
réduction de 10 1 millions de barils par
jour c'est ça va aider plutôt un petit
peu au moyen long terme parce que pour
le moment comme je disais la production
on est plein alors la production sera
l'homme se ralentisse déjà mais il
arrive à rester va rester bas longtemps
on imagine
oui oui c'est c'est vraiment le cas
comme on a besoin de voir ce qui arrive
après qu'on sorte de la crise
oui mais on verra parce qu'on voit ce
qui est arrivé quand on parle de le
secteur pétrolière mais au moins nous
sommes pas le secteur aérien
moi je souffre beaucoup on va et
tourisme aussi vraiment vraiment il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont vraiment alors
on verra de toute façon le gouvernement
fédéral a évoqué la possibilité
d'annoncer une aide martha hall findlay
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir
merci à vous et prenez